la loi et l'ordre c'est donc un des
principaux chevaux de bataille du
gouvernement rappelle notamment avec
l'imposition de peines plus sévères mais
frédéric ottawa se préoccupe aussi
beaucoup des victimes de ces actes
criminels ça va pas d'hier d'ailleurs
non en fait ça a commencé officiellement
1988 sous l'ère de brian mulroney un
gouvernement progressiste conservateur
et à l'époque il avait décidé de signer
avec tous les ministres de la justice de
toutes les provinces
la déclaration canadienne des principes
fondamentaux de justice soit là typhon
victimes de la criminalité en 2003 a été
mise à jour sous le gouvernement libéral
chrétien mais ce qui est important c'est
que c'est juste une déclaration
donc ça ça veut dire que dans le fond il
n'y a pas eu de droits supplémentaires
garantie qui ont été offerts aux
victimes
les gouvernements rappeur lui est arrivé
avec une charte des victimes oui une
charte en fait qui est vraiment très
récente l'a en fait la majorité des
éléments de cette cette charte ont été
mis en vigueur le 23 juillet 2015 alors
ça offrant fait plusieurs droits congrès
contre congrès pour les victimes d'abord
il ya un droit à l'information c'est à
dire que doit avoir un accès assez clair
et facile à toutes les données du
dossier qui concerne la victime il ya
également un droit important c'est celui
de la protection qui garantit c'est à
dire qu'évidemment on veut éviter toute
intimidation toute menace
on pense bien sûr à la sécurité des
témoins il y aussi et ça c'est
probablement un droit qui est vraiment
centrale dans cette charte c'est le
droit de participation c'est à dire que
la victime se retrouve un peu au centre
des procédures légales devant les
tribunaux donc la victime peut faire une
déclaration peut faire part de ses
inquiétudes par exemple au niveau du
processus elle peut apporter aussi une
photo de la victime
elle peut également assister aux
demandes de mise en libération sous
conditions et de libération
conditionnelle et puis enfin le
quatrième droit c'est celui qui concerne
le droit de demander un dédommagement
alors elle peut en quelque sorte aller
devant les tribunaux pour que celui ci
ordonne en fait aux criminels de payer
toutes les pertes financières qui ont
été encourus par le crime mais s'il
chartier quand même critiqué oui en fait
il ya plusieurs experts juridiques qui
disent d'abord bombay c'est ce sont les
provinces et les territoires qui vont
devoir administrés en fait les impacts
de cette charte et d'une province à
l'autre il ya des opinions qui divergent
et aussi des moyens pour mettre en
pratique cette charte qui divergent
il ya également le côté un peu plus
prévention qui n'existe pas en fait là
dedans les gens disent on devrait
peut-être mettre plus d'argent dans
l'aide directe aux victimes par le biais
de meilleur financement pour les
organismes qui soutiennent ces gens là
et puis aussi il ya tout l'aspect
juridique qui vient peut-être encore
davantage engorger les tribunaux c'est à
dire que bon il ya des démarches qui
vont devoir être fait par ses victimes
donc encore une fois on rajoute d'autres
états et on sait les tribunaux n'ont
déjà pas mal sur l'assiette alors
évidemment on verra ce que ça va se
faire
l'efficacité réelle de cette charte
parce que c'est quand même relativement
nouveau depuis le 23 juillet de cette
année seulement céline mais merci
beaucoup frédéric c'est ce qui met fin
donc à notre dossier de ce soir sur
l'état du canada merci bonsoir